en mayo texas aprobó la ley del aborto
más restrictiva de eeuu prohibiendo el
procedimiento una vez que el embrión
muestra signos de actividad donde va a
estar su corazón
nuestro creador nos de todo el derecho a
la vida y sin embargo millones de niños
pierden su derecho a la vida cada año
por culpa del aborto
because the worst pero un juez federal
lo ve de otra manera ya ha suspendido la
aplicación de la ley a la espera de
nuevos litigios aprobando una petición
de la administración del presidente joe
biden
a las mujeres se les ha impedido
ilegalmente ejercer el control sobre sus
vidas de forma protegida por la
constitución este tribunal no sancionará
ni un día más esta ofensiva privación de
un derecho tan importante
e
la ley prohíbe efectivamente el aborto a
partir de las 6 semanas de embarazo y no
hace excepciones para los casos de
violación o incesto la forma de
aplicarla es única los ciudadanos pueden
demandar a cualquiera que haya
practicado o ayudado a practicar un
aborto y si el caso desemboca en un
juicio se le recompensa con al menos
10.000 dólares incluso con la ley en
suspenso es posible que los servicios de
aborto en texas no se reanuden porque
los médicos siguen temiendo que se les
demande sin una decisión más permanente
la ley forma parte de un impulso más
amplio de los republicanos para imponer
restricciones al aborto políticos
conservadores están estudiando la
posibilidad de aplicar una versión de la
ley de texas en otros estados dirigidos
por los republicanos y su objetivo final
es anular la histórica sentencia de 1973
roe contra wade que legalizó el aborto
en todo el país